Right?
And he,
he looked,
looks like that.
He's like that fire.
I've seen exactly that.
So you want to talk about what that real controllers of the grays are?
It looks like,
sorry,
have you ever had a significant head injury?
What happened to
what happened to you?
You know they're going to NPR piece going on next week.
Cause I apologize in the gun.
I never did that.
What happened?
What happened to your head?
I've been polygraph.
You,
somebody's pile drive to you.
What happened?
How old were you?
There's about 13 1314 many pile drived you and you had to change your
personality.
I got up and punched him in the throat and the head,
Drake anatomy,
I was dead.
Wow.
So was it a friend of the US?
It was like the state wrestling champion,
middle white and he,
his cousin or something in the Dallas was like this like,
you know,
got me down.
I was never starting five man.
These people,
here's the thing,
I'm out of victim of racial attacks.
I'm not like Jeffrey or Jessie.
Smaller is,
I fought rednecks and I got my leg broken.
You know by,
so this guy pile drive you in your head,
you knew 13
yeah.
And then what did it do to your personality then?
I had to fight his whole family.
Most his family.
It was a gamechanger.
Did it change,
but did you have any significant change from that head injury?
Sometimes when people have entered juries especially,
it seems like,
you know,
stuff's just got better.
Real.
Oh,
a lot of
serious.
It's like,
dude,
we got to get to the root timing.
That's good timing.
No,
no,
no.
I mean I,
that's happening.
No doubt.
My friend Dave Foley was just on here and he was talking about how he got drunk
and he fell down and cracked his head and it,
it's crazy,
but it cured his depression.
Got a little excited behind this.
Any given time.
If somebody is a regular guy,
I would never start a fight.
They kicked my ass.
Like the average hundred 50 pound guy.
You're probably hearing bias,
but when like a bunch of people are coming after me,
it's like Darth Vader and
I was a kid.
I mean,
I've heard rob
bash somebody's head into the concrete when they attack me.
I got hard.
Hell.
And when the kid dropped you on your head,
what effect did it have on you physically?
It was by the field house because his cousin had attacked me and I'd beat him
up.
And so the state wrestling champ was like a senior comes and goes.
Oh yeah.
He came around and he got up one on my head was bleeding,
like he'd won and I punched him in the neck and broke us.
It had a tracheotomy almost died.
And I was like,
yeah,
he almost killed me.
He was like,
he couldn't,
like,
he slammed me in the ground.
My head's bleeding,
all these stitches right here.
And then he couldn't believe when I got up and said,
well,
you die.
He couldn't understand like the energetic of equivalents.
He couldn't understand being the nail.
You can only understand being the hammer he and understand that.
And then they,
you know,
they took me to jail.
They let me go.
I'm on some tough guy.
The point is,
I'm getting killed.
I'm gonna fight back.
And so Dallas was like,
what happened to your after that?
I mean I uh,
I never ever got knocked out in that one.
Uh,
they slammed my head in the ground and I remember like everybody made a joke
cause the concrete cracked.
Oh chimeras like on the edge of the congress.
He,
he called rob me right into the concrete.
I'm like,
split my head way over,
but let's just write a story.
And I remember just getting up,
I was like,
slow motion puts you right in the neck and the ambulances,
the police came.
That was that story.
Did you go to the hospital?
Okay.
No,
they took me to jail for that,
but then they'd let me go.
They didn't check your head.
Did you tell them you got piled?
Try?
No,
they solved it up.
They sewed it up in the,
in the jail.
They didn't like check to see if you had a severe concussion or a I'm dermal
hematoma.
No.
Wow.
Go ahead.
Joseph had been the one you think that he's a conspiracy theorist cause it got
dropped on his head.
Uh,
I think,
I think there's something,
there's something to people that have had head trauma that become brilliant at
speaking things.
It's true.
The blast got dumped like his job,
his name is Cory strange.
The only reason he won when he was battered or power for the me is he does he
have like fucking,
he had six packs of the Arnold Schwarzenegger Black Dude.
He waited and gloated while blood was coming out of my head.
Oh Shit.
He lost.
Was He loaded?
Yeah.
Um,
but you're,
you broke the concrete with your head.
That's big.
No,
you didn't.
The concrete didn't actually break in it.
Maybe it did,
but they made the job.
Okay.
So either a dinner got knocked out.
He's still got spiked on it.
Call me.
No.
Do getting spine your head on the concrete.
Shogun myself with other people for fun.
I've never been knocked out.
Okay.
So I don't think one time a guy here named got drove hold daggers.
Incorrect.
You're incorrect.
So you,
you absolutely as a kid barely tapped his head,
he would have been knocked out.
Maybe not.
It doesn't matter.
Like sometimes people get knocked out through severe head injury.
Sometimes they don't.
Sometimes they're head of the ratchet.
Hold on.
Sometimes they never lose consciousness.
You can't think that they always lose consciousness.
Sometimes it's cracked out.
I will see like numbers like I was a robot and then red I would see like
remember she sees random.
Yeah.
I was like no,
I'm not kidding.
No,
that's your story.
That's your story dude.
Man When you get dang there's something about getting dinged with a punch and
you see that flash and you realize that you let your central nervous system is
like 30% functionally like whoa.
The variable but very weird feeling.
She Joe's done it.
That's what the people say.
She stars.
Yeah.
That's what it looks at.
Ferring said,
oh Hollywood stars because they'd seen the stars.
Like each star is like a whole data bank and I remember like some dude choking
me and like guys are like,
somebody was like pulling a knife out and she's at knife point out your and
at that point you are she everything for only those minutes when everything's
clear it's like survival emotions.
But then you see like,
like the wars and the attacks,
the submarines of the spacecraft and like,
it's like when you dial into that it's like total war.
It's like,
didn't you say that when your friends would choke you out you'd have with these
long dreams?
Oh yeah.
No,
no,
no.
It'd be off for a couple percent in junior high.
Sixth,
seventh,
eighth grade because we,
I got choked out a couple of our times.
I finally stopped and there'd always be like,
guys like it's incredible.
We do this during lunch and we'd go back and like someone press on their
arteries and the bad times when you hit your habit and be like one time like I
remember this one time I,
they choke me out.
And also it was like a black knight with a sword goes in like a tax me on this
horse and then why.
And then I was like in England thousands of years ago and I had this wife for
these kids and it was a whole lifetime like taking care of them and like growing
food,
like a kid starved to death or died.
And it was like just those moments where like whole lives,
dead kids,
everything.
That's what I'm saying.
Like you dial in to all those ancestors and it was like my kids and kids
starving to death and like people attacking us.
And so you think all that information from your ancestors somehow or another
encoded somewhere in deadline coated Joe.
That makes sense.
If you think about what reincarnation must feel like,
you know when,
when people have that feeling,
they felt this feeling that they live before our whole bodies are everybody
before us.
Right?
Well it's not quite exactly.
So people,
they underestimate like,
oh I live before.
No,
they all live before they would also explain certain fears that people just have
as children.
Like children have a fear of animals.
Like you see an animal with big teeth.
Children have ever been attacked by k but their ancestors got killed by them.
Yeah.
They probably got attacked by some bear somewhere and you know,
and somehow or another they got through and they survived and that left her
side.
The whole tribe.
Yup.
It's,
it makes sense how animals learn things.
I mean,
animals just know things.
My dog would epigenics they have stuff where they can take 10 generation
chickens enclosed closed ut did a study on this like 20 years ago and fly a hawk
over.
They all ranch here.
They fly triangle.
Nobody here.
The exact shape of a hawk makes all the chickens run because they've,
it's,
it's programming.
Exactly.